for the first time Twitter is
fact-checking some of President Trump's
tweets the company added a link to quote
get the facts you can see the link there
below two of mr. Trump's tweets
yesterday those tweets claimed without
any evidence that mail-in voting leads
to fraud the link if you follow it takes
you to another page with more complete
information about those ballots and
there are questions this morning about
why twitter has not taken this step
earlier Paula Reid is at the White House
for us Paula good morning Twitter is a
private company you can do what it likes
but I imagine the president is not happy
about it
good morning Tony well part the
president is accusing Twitter of
interfering in the 2020 presidential
election and of stifling free speech but
since making those accusations last
night the president has tweeted or
retweeted at least 20 times thank you
very much everybody
twitter has become a political flash
point after flagging two of the
president's recent tweets in a statement
the company said the president's
messages about mail-in ballots contain
potentially misleading information about
voting processes and have been labeled
to provide additional context the social
media company has been facing pressure
after another unsubstantiated claim by
the President where he pushed a baseless
conspiracy theory accusing cable news
host and former congressman joe
scarborough of killing his former staff
member lori class Udhas she suffered a
heart condition that caused her to fall
and hit her head in scarborough's office
in 2001 a medical examiner ruled her
death an accident in a letter Lori's
widower asked Twitter to delete the
president's tweets saying the President
of the United States has taken something
that does not belong to him the memory
of my dead wife and perverted it for
perceived political gain president Trump
was asked if he'd seen the letter I'm
sure that ultimately they want to get to
the bottom of it and it's a versary
situation but Twitter declined saying
simply we are deeply sorry about the
pain these statements and the attention
they are drawing are causing the family
the debate over the accuracy of the
president's Twitter account comes as the
administration faces criticism for mixed
signals during the corona virus pandemic
he's a fool an absolute fool to talk
that way
former Vice President Joe Biden defended
his decision to wear a mask Tuesday
after President Trump shared a tweet
mocking him but it presents and projects
his leadership presidents are supposed
to lead not engage in falling and be
falsely masculine president Trump
questions a decision even though his own
administration recommends wearing cloth
face coverings in public settings where
social distancing is difficult Joe Biden
can wear a mask but he was standing
outside with his wife perfect conditions
perfect weather their inside they don't
wear masks and so I thought it was very
unusual that he had one on Biden says
not wearing masks is costing lives and
in response to the president's
accusations that he's been hiding in his
basement Biden said that's working out
pretty well referencing recent polls
showing him leading the president in key
states Anthony
Paula thank you